in this installment we're going to
explore the future of Brad's where it's
all headed as to how brands will
function in our lives and what it means
for us as designers over the next 100
years this three-part series entitled
the 22nd century brand is brought to you
by design Singapore the national agency
for design enabling Singapore to use
design for economic growth and to
improve lives
in these discussions we will be looking
at the origin of brands how brands
function in our contemporary cultural
landscape and the future of brands where
it's all headed my name is hunter Chara
I'm the founder and CEO of an
international brand design consultancy
called syndicate X over the past 25
years I've had the opportunity to work
with some of the world's leading
organizations across culture commerce
and technology and I've helped them
develop clear brand stories and I've
helped them articulate their value
proposition I've worked with
multinational corporations such as
Netflix Nike GE Unilever Lululemon OD
and Asics to some of the world's leading
museums and cultural institutions
including the Victoria and Albert Museum
and the John F Kennedy Center for the
Performing Arts through these
collaborative partnerships I've had the
opportunity to see how brands really
work and to witness the power they have
in our collective consciousness in our
first discussion we looked at the origin
of brands tracing their cultural meaning
from the Roman Empire through the advent
of the 21st century then we looked at
brands today and the ship that has taken
place to make brands themselves the
platform for participation and exchange
in this installment we're going to
explore the future friends where it's
all headed and look at some recent case
studies and begin to give us some
insights as to how brands will function
in our lives and what that means for us
as designers over the next 100 years so
let's start with a question where our
brand is going and how will they be
different especially after covin 19 well
there are many uncertainties in a
postcode in nineteen world there are
certain trends in our recent history
that begin to indicate an exciting
future the brands of today are
participatory it seems we now have the
opportunity to create brands that are
responsive and the brand itself can
allow users to help drive the image
values and reputation of an organization
in the twentieth century
singular artists control the image of
Brad's more recently the tools of brand
design were made democratic and put in
the hands of the people today brands
themselves are driven by our input and
can change according to how we interact
with that brand one of my favorite
examples of a project that I've worked
on this 2012 is know Canada and it's a
project that might begin to suggest how
brands can grow and thrive and indeed
become more visually rich and
sophisticated with the increased
participation of users
[Music]
this is a project I helped lead when I
was the CEO of Bruce Mouw design and
represents a team effort of an
incredibly talented group of global
designers but it's more than that it
also represents the input and action
thousands of users worldwide that's me
in 2012 launching the no Canada project
the studio's of WNYC radio New York City
our team was asked to develop a brand
campaign to educate an American audience
about Canada in the 21st century in our
initial research we determined that in
spite of the fact that Canada was the
most heavily branded nation on earth it
still had an image problem especially in
the United States indeed Canada like
many multinational corporations has
identity standards or what we might call
brand guidelines which govern the usage
of the brand of Canada these standards
are incredibly thorough they established
the do's and don'ts the government of
canada wordmark
brand system and language they
established the hierarchy organization
of official government agencies in both
English and in French even rules for
effective communication which in effect
are the diplomatic voice Canada both at
home and abroad
but somehow in spite of this nearly
obsessive level control over Canada's
visual expression we found there was
still not an identifiable brand for the
country as part of our research we
interviewed some of the key stakeholders
of 21st century Canada
including the author and artist Douglas
Coupland he shared with us an amazing
formulation when he said Canada doesn't
need a redesign I like us just the way
we are this was a massive breakthrough
for our team on this project and began
to change the way I thought about the
design of brands for my other clients
instead of simply trying to create a new
image or icon we just tried to showcase
what was already there
[Music]
we went through an editorial process we
started with the most identifiable
international image of Canada the
national flag that was adopted in the
1960s
we then removed the maple leaf and then
used the remaining red bars to frame
everything that we felt was fun
innovative exciting and beautiful about
Canada in the 21st century we called the
campaign know Canada an invitation to
learn more about this remarkable place
we made this short film to launch the
campaign
and then designed the entire brand
system how no Canada should appear in
print urban environments as advertising
in events and even pop-up installations
in major cities how no Canada could work
in diplomatic quarters or even simply as
a retail brand it was a pretty
remarkable time no Canada launched on
Canada Day July 1st 2012 within the
first 24 hours and went viral in the
next couple of days was all over the
news and social media people especially
young Canadians loved it you can see
some of the tweets at the positive
response that we got to this design work
we loved it too the won awards it
allowed me to lecture all over the world
including at the National Design Center
in Singapore and I was able to become
something of an expert on branding the
21st century nation but once the
campaign was over we were in a bit of a
loss what should we do with this brand
people loved it and it created an open
and democratic image of Canada in the
21st century we simply decided to make
an app that would allow everyone to
create an image of the brand of Canada
we then gathered all of the
user-generated content onto a gallery
website and soon this gallery of images
formed a popular image of the country we
actually put the brand of the nation
into the hands of the people you can see
some of the work that was submitted
there are certain recurring themes and
of course Canadians tried again and
again to replace the missing maple leaf
with other maple leafs that they found
in their everyday lives this project
represented huge shift in my thinking
about design and the contemporary brand
and where brands are going in the future
I'm making a brand open democratic
participatory I could now see a
corresponding increase in engagement and
as I began to think about that for
consumer brands it was not hard to
imagine increase sales deeper
affiliation for companies and
organizations with their key target
audiences more recently I've been
intrigued by a brand called deep hop
it's fashion platform that has created a
community marketplace that allows
designers makers and shoppers to express
their own individuality
the more users who participate the
richer the experience becomes to my mind
Bradley deep hop begins to represent the
future of how brands that create
like-minded communities can begin to
control the marketplace of the next
decades whereas the old model was that a
logo stood for the reputation of a brand
today the reputation actually stands
before the logo and we're moving back
towards a place where there are
authentic relationships and
conversations between brands and
customers the value is once again
replacing artifice an image is being
displaced by action and the authentic
purpose and the fundamental mission of
an organization is once again a
differentiate those brands that are
founded on principle and driven by great
design are far more likely to create the
deep emotional connections that keep
their customers coming back and not
surprisingly it has led to increased
awareness deeper affiliation and
ultimately a growth in sales
in this context the role of the designer
shifted again today the designer is more
of an impresario bringing together the
right people and opportunities
synthesizing the various inputs that are
responsive to changing cultural and
economic conditions the impresario and
historical terms someone who puts on a
show and in the world of contemporary
brand design it's all about bringing the
right people and projects together
when I started our grand design
consultancy syndicate I started with the
radical proposition I only wanted to
work with the people I love and trust
and work on those projects will we felt
a deep connection to the mission of our
clients I feel this authentic alignment
between design principles and corporate
mission is one of the dynamics that is
leading to more responsive and
ultimately responsible brands and
ideally it leads to work that is more
efficient of a higher quality more
sustainable this all leads to more
impactful results for organizations the
customers that they serve to me this is
an incredibly exciting moment for both
designers and for brands brands can do
more and communicate more directly with
their clientele than ever before friends
can get immediate feedback which allows
them to customize their image messaging
and create opportunities that are
specific and personal they can literally
respond to the needs of their customers
and while we have seen there are many
unknowns for the world of design it will
be defined by the creative thinkers who
can flow seamlessly between disciplines
and understand global business trends
technology and culture but mostly it
belongs to those who stay true to the
mission
[Music]
[Music]